Well, welcome, Jon. It's great having you here with
us. And we'll be hearing from you very shortly in your distinguished lecture.
But we take a little time out to say hello a little more
informally at our fireside chat without the fire today.
Anyway, just a little bit maybe about your background and how you got interested
in computer science and where did that interest come from to start with?
Let's see. So, yeah, I guess where the interest came from -- in high school I was,
I think I sort of wanted to be a math major. I mean, actually from some early
phase I either wanted to be like a math major or fiction writer or a lawyer,
I think, but gradually it was all sort of coalesced towards something more technical. Also that was
kind of the era when the Apple 2 Plus had just appeared and I liked writing programs in the Apple 2
plus and I liked writing games my friends could play in the school library on floppy disks and things,
but I somehow didn't imagine that was like a field of study, it was
just a hobby you do. So the striking thing was when I got to college,
as an undergrad at Cornell to discover there was actually an academic field of computer
science with some rather inspirational faculty who are teaching courses in it.
I ended up double majoring in math and computer science. And I think my
interest in computer science was sort of toward the theoretical end of things,
my interest in math. But then sort of in the mid-90s, 1996, '97 after grad
school, I was doing a post-doc at IBM at Almaden with Prabhakar Raghavan.
And he made the argument, this amazing opportunity, the
Web, sort of like the personal computer in the '80s,
seems like a glorified hobby that people were playing around with, but there's a lot going on here.
I began thinking about questions about organizing information
on the Web. And with Eva Tardos in grad school,
I had done so much work on graph algorithms. I thought one
thing I contribute here is my understanding of graphs.
And so thinking about the length structure of the Web made me think you
really need to understand the human system to understand what's going on.
And the plan for me was really a lot of fun, there was a
mathematical aspect thinking about the network structure.
But it tapped into all of these other sort of fascinations I had from early on
in high school with narrative and law and policy and social science and all of
that showed up in the Web and you have yet to understand all these things.
I think somehow I ended up in this mix of topics that I find interesting now.
That actually was a really good explanation of what
others might see as a Venn diagram with some interesting intersections.
I remember reading your Hubs and Authority work talking about Web, structure of the Web back in the
'90s and thinking about what this might mean for both the science for understanding the mixture of
human interests and human generated content and human interest in accessing that content and the
algorithms that we could actually sort of use to capture and to optimize various kinds of objectives.
Curious to hear your reflection about, describe more about what you were doing with the Hubs
and Authority work and what that meant you think for the evolution of thinking about the Web.
Right. So, I mean, when I first started thinking about the Web, it was --
fundamentally it seemed like it was an information retrieval problem on a giant text corpus.
We put a lot of documents out there and we want to find the documents that have the terms that we want.
But when I began thinking about the kinds of queries I myself was trying to solve and
actually at the time sort of summer of '96 I was moving for a year to a new place San Jose,
I now live in California. So you're doing a lot of research
about where can I buy this thing from my apartment.
And so you're constantly on the Web and it wasn't -- it was often the activity was to try to
sort of organize this giant mass of information to figure out what are the good sources.
And so I began to discover a thing I myself was doing as I chased down the length structure
and engage in some meta awareness of what am I doing as I try to buy furniture for my apartment
or try to find what are the reading groups that are meeting about different things.
And it was clear that the information about which were the important pages was not intrinsic to the page.
When you found the right page it wasn't that it said the
word you wanted more often or in bigger font or anything.
It was you only knew it was the right answer because all the things that pointed to
it. That was the argument that links were somehow providing this crucial evidence.
But the other thing that was happening was that there really was this two-sided nature to it.
Because there were these good pages. But once we found a few pages you
realized that there were these other pages that had linked to all of them.
You sort of missed them on your first pass; but in retrospect
there was this one page that had you listen to it.
It actually listed the three things you ended up finding interesting. It wasn't just that,
it actually listed six things. Now that I'm taking that page
more seriously, I should figure out what the other three were.
Had the top three, maybe these other three were great also. These were
these really powerful Web pages and somebody had done the work before you.
To create a hub.
It was someone who had been faced roughly with the same task you
had and they had done a very good solving and documenting their solution.
Let's go back and learn from them. So once we find a good
hub, certain things now seem like better authorities.
And you say, okay, they're good authorities, good hubs linked to authorities.
And at that point as a computer scientist you think we should iterate this.
If we have better estimates for our authorities we should find better estimates for our hubs.
And the appealing thing is that the iteration had some very natural structure and it exposed this
two-sided nature to all of these topics that there was the thing itself and then there were the pages
that all linked to the thing itself and in some ways served as the glue that held it all together.
This idea about this human effort to organize that's represented implicitly
in lots of activity on the Web and there's stuff being pointed at as the gold mine,
the gold nuggets information that someone else has put there because it's the information itself.
Exactly. And in a way it's like we can all be basketball fans, for example, and we can all --
we're all unified by the fact we all refer to the same basketball
stars even if we never directly interact with the basketball stars,
their existence somehow serves to create a community among us.
Right. It seems that those ideas were so nascent in the
mid to late 90s coming in part to all the contributions you were making.
In advance of like page rank and other structural analyses that people now, they
say are core even what's going on in these algorithms anymore are sort of at the
root of how we look at Web and how we look at information retrieval and indexing,
which is interesting. Now you had a comment there? I'll say that
the recent work you're doing I think most recently in some ways,
maybe last couple of years, of course you do many things. But I've
been very fascinated to see you bringing together policy law,
social science in issues around fairness which have come to the fore lately when people rightly
concerned about systematic biases in tools that might amplify them through great use.
And you want to talk about the work, includes criminal justice, for example.
Absolutely. This is something that I started thinking about sort of around 2011,
2012 and actually it began with a series of conversations with
Sendhil Mullainathan, a behavioral economist at Harvard.
We had been undergrads together at Cornell.
I didn't know that.
Yeah, we actually have -- my second paper and his first
paper was actually a PodC 1993 paper that came out of a joint,
class project jointly we did in Keith Marzul's operating systems class. We submitted it.
I would never even have connected Keith to both of you
at the time. Thanks for making that little meta link for me now.
Exactly. It's a feature. We both took this really inspiring class
from him and just poured a lot of effort into doing a class project for him.
And at the time it's funny that Sendhil was -- Dick Saylor was at Cornell at the
time and Sendhil was very excited about these ideas in behavioral economics.
And we went our separate ways professionally. And starting,
2011 and 2012, it was Sendhil who initiated the contact,
and at this point we're thinking about very similar things because he had been
very focused on human decision-making and human experts and high stakes settings
and even low stake settings and the kinds of systematic errors that people make.
And I was thinking about algorithms which are decision-making entities. We're
now in these situations where we can ask what's the interface between --
and it did feel like around 2011 and 12 there was this missing subject where we had human
computer interaction but there was sort of this emerging human machine learning interaction,
how do humans interact with big data resources and the algorithms that make predictions based on that.
The human AI interaction more broadly.
Broadly. Probably absolutely.
Please go on.
Absolutely. I think of those all bundled together at this point.
And so we looked at domains where the situation called for a prediction.
The idea being there are lots of decisions that human beings make and
it's a fascinating question to ask which of these can be automated,
which ones can't. But let's do it on the cases where what people are doing is making predictions
and asking what we can learn about the human process and also whether there are gains to be had.
And so we start talking to Jens Ludwig, a public policy researcher at the University of Chicago,
one of whose domains is crime policy. He had these interesting datasets on judges making bail decisions.
And the reason to look at bail, if you look at criminal justice, obviously one of the highest
stakes settings where experts are making decision that have enormous impact on people's lives,
if you look at the pipeline of decisions that get made there,
decisions about arrest, decisions about pretrial detention and bail,
present at trial, sentencing, parole, many, many things, if you ask where in that
pipeline is a person doing something that most resembles a pure prediction task,
at least according to the law that's arguably on bail, because what the law says a judge
should do on bail is to release the person before trial if they believe with high probability
they'll return for their court appearance without committing a crime in the meantime.
They shouldn't be thinking about their eventual guilt or innocence shouldn't be
thinking about what's the incentive effect of my decision on future defendants,
you should be making that prediction. Now there's a whole important
set of questions about are they making exactly that prediction.
But there's at least a case where we could come in with the data we have and [indiscernible].
So this was an appealing problem. I roped in Jure Leskovec, my former post-doc, and his student,
Teema [inaudible], who is graduating right now.
Jure is a former intern here at Microsoft Research. Really appreciated sharing his intellect.
Yeah. He's been an enormous pleasure to work with now
over a decade. And so the five of us set on this project,
which actually took a number of years, really started this some
summer, got going with the five us in the summer of 2013.
And so there were a lot of challenges here. So as you said, one challenge is that the data is biased.
If we think about this as a prediction problem, there's features and there's a label. So the
features are maybe the administrative data that we have on past arrests for what types of crimes,
past convictions, what was the status of the person at the time of the arrest.
Information that the algorithm was able to see in some kind of tabular form.
And then the label is if they got released did they return
for their court appearance without committing a crime.
On the feature side, of course, the administrative data is contaminated
by incredibly differential rates of policing and in different areas.
And so an arrest does not necessarily mean the same thing
in all different areas and per unit level of crime,
it doesn't mean the same things. And that becomes a big issue. It's very
much in the spirit of what people worry about when we say we're taking
biases that already came and already predated this moment in the courtroom.
On the label, this notion of predicting crime while they're released, we don't have a label of crime,
we have a label arrest. All we can do is see if they were arrested. Even
failure to appear has a lot of correlation with socioeconomic status.
So there are issues both on the kind of input and on the
output. Then there are the methodological challenges.
And the biggest one we faced was the fact if the judge releases someone, we can see what happened.
If the judge detains someone for trial, we don't know what would have happened.
You have to make it a counterfactual argument.
Exactly, counterfactual argument. The more we thought about the more we realized,
this is a feature of many domains. Like in the sort of decision-making, the medical domain,
which you're very familiar with. If the doctor applies a treatment or doesn't apply a treatment,
we're now in two different worlds and we only get certain labels about things. If I choose,
if I have -- if I choose to hire someone, I see how they
moved on at my company. If I choose not to hire them,
they go somewhere else, I'm not going to know how they would have done in the environment of my company.
Often we get this one-sided label. It's not just randomly one-sided,
it's based on the decision the decision-maker themselves made.
The question is how do we demonstrate some kind of a gain or not through
algorithms, if we only have labels in that kind of situation.
And so at the core of what we were doing was to exploit some natural variation where we could actually --
and so the kind of -- the sort of few-sentence version of the trick that's at the
heart of the paper is that in many things you have defendants sort as if randomly,
quasi randomly assigned to multiple judges who differ in their rates of
leniency. So I have a judge who releases 80 out of every 100 people,
or I have a judge who releases 90 out of every 100 people.
Now I have a new way of releasing 80 out of 100 people,
which is I can send them to the judge who releases 90 out of
100, sort them all by risk as computed by the algorithm,
use the algorithm to detain the ten people it finds the riskiest in that set of 90. The judge releases 90.
We contract it back to 80. Now we have a set of 80 defendants who we detained. Now we have two
ways to detain 80 defendants: We send them to the judge who is 80 percent lenient or we do this
hybrid human algorithmic rule where the human overshoots and the algorithm scales it back.
Now it's now an apples-to-apples comparison in some sense. And there we could
demonstrate actually there's a lower crime rate on the hybrid human algorithmic rule,
that somehow the worst decisions the judge is making are
pretty simply bad and if you could simply fix those,
you could leave most of the judge's decisions completely intact and basically improve at the margins.
It's sort of intriguing to us because it was an interesting alternative
to the dichotomy between should we have humans do the work;
should we fully automate? That's not really a binary decision. It's really that
there are cases where the algorithm can be improving things at the margin.
You can say I'm going to come in and fix the worst decisions. It's
almost somewhere in one of our papers we make this analogy to it's --
in the realm of cars we think about human drivers or self-driving
cars. But of course long before we ever got near self-driving cars,
we had all sorts of algorithmic assistance computer assistance in the
vehicle that sort of is preventing you from making the worst mistakes.
Emergency braking situations.
Exactly. Emergency braking. Parking assist.
Yesterday, I'm not sure when this video will be watched, but just yesterday
we had a report of an Uber self-driving car with human oversight killing a pedestrian,
unfortunately, and it's kind of a landmark in this kind of thing. It's the kind of
situation we've been worried about with automation being applied in the world.
And in some discussions people said, oh, the cars will
likely save many lives, I think over 36,000 last year,
deaths and over a million injuries in the United States alone. And over a million worldwide,
we hear deaths from automobile accidents, and certainly these cars
will, even if they have these rough edges will be saving lives,
but there's the sense when it's an automated system, there's a high
standard we have for how it behaves and the values it represents.
Thoughts on where we're going with these kinds of automation and any safety clerical areas.
This is a fascinating debate. Should we hold algorithms to a higher
standard. And on the one hand something appealing about saying that,
we should hold algorithms to a higher standard. On the
other hand, you're giving up something really tangible.
There are a lot of lives that eventually will be saved if you
decided not to hold algorithms to quite as a a high standard.
You're paying for this decision at a high cost. And I think that's what makes this so tricky.
I do think it's interesting -- I mean I've been sort of trying to understand some about the issue of why --
I think I do, and everyone I talk to feels this particularly strong reaction to the algorithm,
the algorithm caused harm. The algorithm did something. And I think if we take
some of the sort of pedagogical examples where we see algorithms causing harm,
where the algorithm is in a no win situation, swerve left or right, it's going to kill or hurt someone.
In those kind of situations, which are awful to contemplate,
humans in those situations, where it's an awful situation,
it's very hard to say why they did what they did. Something happened very fast, tried their best,
made essentially a random decision, something terrible happened; it was an accident, as we call it,
right? One problem with the algorithms of course, we can go in
and we can find millisecond by millisecond what it was doing,
why it decided to turn left and not right, what was it actually thinking about. And
I feel like if we step back since we always tend to anthropomorphize these things,
we attach more moral opprobrium to things that are premeditated,
things you thought it through and did the bad thing anyway.
And the problem is everything that the algorithm does, most of these algorithms does are premeditated,
because we can see what it was thinking; whereas, with the human at some level
we'll never know what they were thinking they were trying their best --
Under bounded resources, all in real time.
Exactly.
Using best intuitions.
Exactly. And some of the algorithm was somehow engaging in the calculation
about things where we think it's morally questionable to engage a calculation.
That I think is part of the reason why we ascribe --
Makes it also certainly, brings it into salience the fact that at the moments
of decision-making you see uncertainty represented potentially and an action that was taken and
an objective function that's clear and you can state it now in a sensitive machine somewhere.
Someone said here's the trade you make in this situation; here's the cost and benefits.
Yeah.
So that explicitness I think also brings up questions where the
question should have been to begin with even with implicit decision-making.
That's the question. And of course you've thought a lot about these issues. But I do feel like a
lot of people genuinely feel like even having thought about it that there's some advantage to living in a
world of strategic ambiguity where we never actually calculate the choice between two terrible alternatives.
So you've done many pieces of work, a lot of them, as you said, at these interesting intersections,
looking at communities, how communities form on the Web and their nature and
structure, how links get formed and the power of linked prediction and so on.
And we see daily now in our various services like Facebook and LinkedIn,
some comments on directions there and why that's so exciting.
I mean, if I sort of look over the sort of longer history of this,
I feel like if I back up to where we were talking about Web search,
circa '96, '97, I think at the time the conceptualization I had was
the Web is this vast universal library of all human knowledge.
You go and you dip in the library and you pull out knowledge from it. I feel like there was
a period 2004-2006 was a sort of really important period in the development of the Web.
It was really a moment when somehow the level of participation, the technology, the bandwidth had
reached where people could actually step out from behind their Web pages and interact more directly.
It was no longer I interact with you because my Web page linked to your Web page. We're directly commenting
on each other's content and tagging each other's content and collaboratively authoring something.
It's kind of interactive phase transition or experiential phase transition.
Exactly. A lot of the things we now take as sort
of pillars of the current Web all came about right there.
In that two to three-year period you see the creation of Facebook, YouTube, Twitter. All of them sort of --
all of this social media sort of kind of speciating sort of really quickly in that period.
I want to mention I remember a time being interviewed by somebody on the work we did,
which is of your interest as well, with Jure Leskovec on theory separation and it created a flurry.
I remember trying to explain to a well-known moderator on I think it was on CNBC what Facebook was,
what social media was. And I remember having to come up with like:
Let me explain this in 20 words or less but it had to be explained.
Yeah, it's amazing, things move so fast that things that you could
present as novelties three or four years later feel like common knowledge.
And, yeah, I remember the first Google faculty summit they brought us all in
there, we have this amazing thing called Gmail that offers a gigabyte of
storage and on the horizon is an amazing new prototype called Google Maps.
That was, what, only 12, 13 years ago.
Interesting how fast that has happened. But back to this idea of community and interaction.
Exactly. So I think that period suddenly people were interacting
directly. And certainly that struck me as a very important moment.
And even to the extent I've been thinking of the Web graph for sort of ten years up to that point,
the idea of human social networks being reflected online I think it's been a very -- a very powerful thing.
And it certainly brought about a new kind of information seeking behavior, a new way
in which we engage with things where rather than just go out and look for things,
it comes to you through your network of friends as it did in the offline world. And obviously it's sort of,
anytime one talks about that now, one has to think about sort of the way it's evolved
in the past few years where you now have this combination of your real friends from
the offline world sharing information with you and commercial entities sharing
information with you and all of that somehow happening in a big superposition,
this is what you're being exposed to now online.
I want to come back to that topic in a second. But I want to route you through
thinking about some of your contributions with your collaborators on incentives and Web activity.
You've done some really fabulous work on badges, for example, and I'm trying
to understand how different kinds of programs were reinforcing work,
for example, say in a crowdsourcing system or system where people are helping each other, GitHub,
for example. How you can actually shape what people do based on the design of the merit program.
Can you say a little more about that?
Yes, so this was something that we became interested in because
in the online world there became this proliferation of badges.
If you do this much of activity you get a badge. If you do this
much this frequently over some period of time you get a badge.
These had incentivizing effects. People would set these as
goals for themselves. And some work that Jure Leskovec,
Ashton Anderson and Dan Huttenlocher and I did, you
actually see the effect, where people near the milestone,
their activity increased. Then they hit the milestone and it
dropped off. They're clearly aiming for that as the finish line.
And you end up with this sort of interesting badge design problem or badge
placement problem where it's almost as though you had people sort of steering
through the space of activities and in a way we actually first discovered it this,
we were just looking at the activity as it were just organic activity and we saw
everyone was kind of torquing in a strange direction in this part of the space.
We all felt like astrophysicists saying there's clearly some gravitating body here that's bending the flow.
We have to figure out what it is because it's invisible to us.
Dark matter.
And you go look there's a badge right there and
everyone is bending around it as they try to get the badge.
You pick up your telescope, you see the badge coming into view with the scope.
Exactly. And you're actually -- like plot the flow lines and you would see this.
So that becomes --
I always thought when I saw those figures in your paper, magnetic filings.
That's exactly right. And so what's nice is you can build some models in which it's actually,
in retrospect, an intuitive model that if a badge is very far away, there's a good
chance I'm going to leave the system before it ever becomes relevant to me.
If I'm very close to a badge I'm probably going to make it. It actually
acquires more value and actually has more drawing power the closer I get to it,
almost like one of these physical objects. It becomes a design problem, where should I put the badges.
So now it's up to me, I'm trying to sort of create some beautiful shape with the iron filings.
I can put the magnets, bar magnets wherever I want. And it does
have an effect. If I create an incentive that comes too soon,
I get everyone to participate but pretty quickly they're
through the incentive and I've lost control of them.
If I put it too far away, seems hopeless. There's some optimal distance at which to put the incentive.
So it pulls people toward it in a way that's achievable. And so
that's -- so I think there's a very interesting design space there.
Now I want to come back to an earlier topic. I told you I was
going to go through incentives this idea of mixing ideas of incentives and design,
oft we say well-intentioned designers who have users in mind or learnings or the community in mind when
they do a design like this to other incentives and objectives to the point where we see the possibility
in this new connected world with all sorts of entities including commercial entities to do large scale
designs aimed at manipulation which might not necessarily be in line with the interests of the individuals.
And the prospect, for example, and the possibility that some of the best machine learning people
coming out of our departments and organizations now will go off and spend time with large scale
datasets and machine learning algorithms to optimize time of engagement on a timeline,
the duration, for example, or the other kinds of behaviors on the Web that might be aimed at commerce,
at maximizing profits and therefore being sort of -- they're being great incentives by entoÿÿes
to create algorithmic approaches to doing adversarial in some ways attacks on human attention.
Where is this going and how might we address this potential problem?
So that's obviously an interesting question. And here I think the challenge
is this problem is so hard that I sort of hesitate to say anything that sounds
prescriptive because I really don't think I've thought hard about it enough to really --
and I've thought pretty hard about it. But I just feel like it's an incredibly hard thing.
I should say that it is not a completely new issue. So as a child, I watched
a lot of beer commercials because I liked watching football and baseball,
and because I liked football and baseball and I was age eight, I also saw lots of beer commercials.
You could say was that the socially optimal allocation of people's
attention. But it was very much the state of the world,
adversarial attack. Most of the professional sports was underwritten ultimately by advertising.
If you liked professional sports or any kind of entertainment, you would see lots of advertising.
And often advertising not particularly well targeted to your particular interest.
And I think that was some of the optimism around online media that the things
that are going to be generating revenue ought to at least be tailored to things
appropriate for you and in the end isn't that actually a better kind of advertising.
So I think we've always created media that tries to
optimize for engagement, tries to optimize for attention.
We've tended to do it with more qualitative tools.
Like, for example, when we were growing up even now, an episode
of Twilight Zone would hit that moment and someone would say we'll be right back,
don't go away.
Exactly, yeah. And all of these were sort of lower data attempts to get -- so I
don't think in terms of the intent something new is happening that wasn't happening then.
I think as you're saying what has changed is that there's much more data and therefore much more ability
to do really sort of surgically precise interventions but I think it's an activity that has sort of been
true for as long as sort of humans have created media to attract the attentions of other human beings.
But at some point quantity becomes quality. And so I think it does bring definitely new issues into play.
And the extent to which we should ask to what extent is people's immediate
interest in seeking out what kind of activates or energizes them,
to what extent should we trade that off with long-term gain. And that's not just a societal interest.
Even for the platforms themselves. In the end platforms are perhaps
less worried about whether you spend the next one hour on the platform,
whether you remain an engaged participant over the long term. If you're doing something
in the short term that keeps people emotionally aroused and on the platform,
but in the long term they feel bad about the experience, that's neither in society's interest,
nor is it in the platform's interest.
I guess you can imagine a concern being you do both, you arouse them and get their interest long term.
And five years from now someone looks back and says, boy, I wish I spent my time in a better way.
And so there is this idea of some movement or some
reflection at level of industry or society more generally,
civil liberties organizations, a time well spent and what does that mean and when does
that run counter to commercial goals with their precision manipulation slash attack
slash optimization of how they would like to have people spend their attention and time.
No, I think it's -- yeah, this is a very important issue which I've -- I've
been thinking about it more and more because it's clearly on everyone's minds.
But it is useful to think back to everything that was said about TV. And
like my generation was supposedly ruined by all the TV that we watched,
all the kind of mindless entertainment, the violent entertainment, all the commercials we were exposed to.
This was why our country was falling behind all the other countries. I got an enormous diet of this kind of
worry and anxiety in the 1980s and it was because there was a media interest motivated by similar things;
they needed to keep an audience that was engaged. I think as we think about
this, I think it's useful to separate it into the parts that are new,
which is how data assists and computation assisted it, is from the parts that old, which is the kind of urge
people providing media and providing content to keep their audiences engaged in ways that worry some of us.
Changing topics to maybe friendlier ones, something
less serious, but still important in terms of time well spent.
When I visited you, gave a talk in 1999, Cornell, gave a keynote and you
hosted me. And I remember when you were dropping me at the airport,
we're back at the hotel, wherever I was going. You had your big bags full of hockey equipment,
you and your wife. And you were going to go out to play ice hockey. Do you still play ice hockey?
I play it less and less. At the time we played
twice a week. And I remember talking about it with you.
And we actually should have had you play when you were there. I think we learned
from our mistake because a couple years later we invited John Lafferty.
I hear he's a good player.
Incredibly good player. And we didn't know that at the time but he says he plays hockey.
We said perfect. He gave the colloquium, went to a quick
dinner, didn't eat too much, brought him to the hockey.
He had to borrow skates that didn't quite fit and a helmet.
Skates.
Exactly. Despite that, the instant he stepped on the ice, oh wait, he's really good.
Because you can tell in a few seconds if someone is really good at this.
Definitely. That was a phase we were both playing twice a week.
I'm about to give a talk soon at Cornell. I'll take you up on this potentially.
But I should add the sad part to this is that over
time we've definitely been -- and obviously you sort of,
becoming parents adds new time constraints and getting busier.
And then I reached a point where I also fear injury.
I mean I would say in our annual intramural league somebody would get nontrivially injured at
least once and I'm definitely keenly aware I don't recover from things as fast these days.
I play ice hockey also. Typically it's on a once-a-week team and I have to say you watch popcorn,
like a Poisson process, injuries will occur. And once in a while
you walk out with an injury and takes a while to recover.
And as you say as you get older, things take a little bit longer to reset.
Yeah.
A few comments about, you talked a little bit about your background, having fun with the
Apple 2 and finding out this is actually a field and having a place to leverage your math and your inclination
to see math actually execute in the real world and have influence and help to interpret the real world.
What kind of advice would you give to, let's say, undergraduates now maybe
finishing up their undergrad careers and how to think about next steps?
That's a great question. And I mean certainly something all of
us have been thrilled at the level of interest in computer science.
It's just been growing rapidly and it's enormous over the past few years. I think one
is to really just think about how broadly the ideas of computing can be applied.
I think almost every area either is being influenced by the ideas of computation or could be.
And so I think it's a great opportunity to really take this as a fundamental body of
knowledge that you can combine with almost anything else that you find interesting.
As I said, in eighth grade I wanted to be a lawyer when I grew up. And it took me a very
long time to finally come back and sort of combine the computation with that interest,
and I was sort of late to the party; people were doing it all along. But I think if you have an interest,
it's almost sure to be compatible with ideas from computing
in some way and that's just how broad the field has become.
And then I think the other thing that I try to advise students, it's easy to see in the
media how we live in an era of big science and all science can be done by giant teams and
your future is to be the person who contributes one tiny data point on some giant plot.
And I think I can't speak for the other sciences and what that
looks like, but in computer science what I think is so exciting,
there's still exciting discoveries to be made. You and the
manageable dataset and your laptop and some new conceptual idea.
And a lot of stuff happens still in groups of two or three or one, with very modest resources.
And there's still amazing things to be discovered there. Obviously there's
also the stuff that happens on big datacenters and some of it needs that.
And if that's what you're interested in, there's room to work in that style.
But it's sort of nice to know that someone working just with a friend of
theirs on a laptop can still do things that attract everyone's attention.
And that's also a very appealing thing about the field; that the important problems are still accessible
and some of them are quite manageable for people who are undergrads or just going to college.
That's a great place to stop. Well, thanks very much. Enjoyed talking to you.
Thanks so much. Good talking to you.
It's a wrap. How was that?
It was fantastic.